ein wütender mob stürmt das herz der
amerikanischen demokratie abgeordnete
fliehen und fürchten um ihr leben
fünf menschen sterben weil der präsident
seine anhänger mit lügen zum widerstand
aufruft ein land in schockstarre und in
angst vor einer weiteren eskalation
ein paar tage später kehrt ford fischer
mit seiner kamera zurück ins kapitol
blumen und plakate erinnern an den
getöteten polizisten brian sich nick
fischer filmte mitten in der
demonstration als die situation außer
kontrolle gerät
wir haben euch einmal begriffen dass die
gewalt deutlich wurde und in dem moment
haben wir alle gedacht dass noch mehr
menschen sterben können und vor das
ganze hier zu ende ist angestachelt von
wilden wahlbetrugs fantasien überrumpelt
trump selbsternannte schatten armee
metall barrikaden und überforderte
polizisten zu wenig für die wilde
aggression der tram pisten die über
wochen mit einem sturm aufs kapital
gedroht hatten empörte ohne corona
masken und vermummte milizionäre männer
mit bärten und frauen mit mager münzen
make america drahtige junge und alte die
bereit sind gesetze mit füßen zu treten
und rechtsextreme verschwörungs anhänger
mit fellmütze ich habe diesen mann schon
einen interviewt er bezeichnet sich als
kino schamane eine anspielung auf die
queen verschwörungstheorie und im
prinzip ist er jemand der alle ebenen
der regierung als korrupt bezeichnet der
schamane wurde mittlerweile verhaftet
rund 80 weitere capitol stürmen im
eiltempo versuchen ermittler die
beteiligten anzuklagen
zur abschreckung um zu verstehen wer die
drahtzieher sind und wie es überhaupt
dazu kommen konnte
wir wissen dass es hinweise gab es gab
viele hinweise auf social media kanälen
über die pläne
entweder haben die richtigen leute davon
erfahren und nichts unternommen oder die
information sind nicht bis zu den leuten
durchgedrungen die davon hätten wissen
sollen egal wie man es sieht es war ein
riesen
das versagen völlig unbeeindruckt von
kameras und sicherheitskräften können
sich die braut vor dem kapitol
versammelt auf ein gemeinsames zeichen
rückt die rechte miliz geschlossen vor
kurz darauf fallen die ersten barrikaden
rechte plattformen befeuern die
aggression und in der menge
bricht jubel aus einer der die szene
kennt ist caleb kane
er war selbst anhänger rechter
verschwörungs mieten heute erforscht er
rechte online-netzwerke trump anhänger
aus der gamer szene live rollenspiele
für die der angriff auf die eigene
regierung zum spiel geworden ist diese
leute leben in einer fantasiewelt für
sie ist es als ob sie teil von
irgendeiner geschichte sind
ich glaube sie begreifen nicht einmal
dass es reale aktionen sind die in der
realen welt auch reale konsequenzen
haben und diese leute haben gerade die
gesamte dynamik im land verändert
in der realen welt war die zunehmende
radikalisierung längst sichtbar
schon im frühjahr 2020 besetzen milizen
das parlament in michigan im spätsommer
verhaftet das fbi 13 personen die
michigans gouverneurin gritsch in
wittmar entführen wollte genau hier in
lenzing beginnt nach der wahl eine der
ersten stoppte stil demonstration
befeuert von der hetze des präsidenten
dort treffen wir anfang november
michelle greg war mitglied einer rechten
bürgermilizen schwer bewaffnet gegen
black live santa corona maßnahmen und
wahlbetrug demonstriert
sie ist teil einer gut vernetzten
bewegung die blind den thesen des
präsidenten die wahlzettel wurden nicht
richtig ausgezählt es wurde viel
betrogen republikanische wahlbeobachter
wurden unter beifall der demokraten am
auszählen gehindert es gibt videos davon
auf twitter und facebook aufwändig tag
uns zensiert erzählen wir den menschen
die wahrheit dass ihre wahl direkt vor
ihren augen gestohlen wurde weil sie den
präsidenten so hassen obwohl er so viel
gutes getan hat die stoppel stil
kampagne nimmt fahrt auf
am 14 november laufen zehntausende beim
million marsch durch washington die
parolen werden immer aggressiver
wir lassen doch nicht 51 der amerikaner
bestimmen wie die anderen 49 prozent zu
leben haben
so funktioniert das nicht wir haben
keine angst das ist unser land niemand
wird uns die freiheit nehmen
[Musik]
auch michelle haben wir als seine frau
kennengelernt die ihre vorstellung von
amerika verteidigen will
sie selbst sei nicht in washington dabei
gewesen die wut der tram pisten aber
teilt sie noch immer da ist es doch
beängstigend wenn nicht einmal ein
gericht sagt hey ihr solltet genau
hinschauen und überprüfen ob eure wahlen
sicher sind das macht mich wahnsinnig
ganz besonders wenn jetzt joe biden an
die macht kommt und sagt wir nehmen euch
die waffen weg abtreibung wird erlaubt
es gibt ein staatliches
gesundheitssystem
all das ist muss meine idee vom
amerikanischen traum
das ideal einer vereinten nationen wurde
unter trümmern begraben
ein wütender mob hat die hallen der
demokratie verwüstet angestachelt durch
einen abgewählten präsidenten
das fbi ermittelt wegen aufruhr und
komplott gegen die vereinigten staaten
verrat steht auf diesem zurückgelassenen
banner eine drohung als sie das capitol
verließen riefen einige
heute ist nicht aller tage abend wir
dürfen uns nicht vertun
die bedrohung ist immer noch sehr real
und glaubwürdig wir wissen dass es eine
erhöhte bedrohungslage in den
vereinigten staaten gibt aber das
heimatschutzministerium hat noch keine
nationale terrorwarnstufe ausgesprochen
um die bedrohungslage anzupassen und der
amtierende heimatschutzminister ist
diese woche zurückgetreten
ganz ehrlich so etwas habe ich noch nie
erlebt
zur vereidigung des neuen präsidenten
wird washington zur hochrisiko zone
schon ab dem wochenende soll es wieder
proteste geben bundesweit diesmal
in vielen städten es sind chaotische
zeiten dazu ein geschwächter
sicherheitsapparat amerikas demokratie
steht unter beschuss